every we approve civilization was built
off the back of slaves
replicants or the future but I can only
like so many what were the challenges in
creating a futuristic world which is
based on a vision of the future from the
past the first movie was a was like a
projection of the 70s and the 80s in the
future and depicted a world that is
different there's no Steve Jobs in the
first Blade Runner so I decided that we
will be a projection and if you drop the
first movie we've created basically an
alternate universe Denis really made a
point of trying to ground this film in a
in reality not in a world of cinematic
references you know everything seemed to
be about how could this how can we make
this possible it's kind of a great
reflection of society and who we are as
humans and where are we heading towards
- if we don't wake up a little bit it's
about seeking identity and holding on to
connection and love as we know it today
we were being hunted by who
they know you're here did you go down
the rabbit hole of thinking about what
makes us human
it's a thing I like that it was linked
with the question that was rose in the
first movie and I like the widow at
movies bringing back those questions
again the original you see you know the
last modeling of Rutger Hauer playing
Roy batty in the film and it's almost
like he's more human than a human that
is the question of this movie what is it
what is it to be human because it really
doesn't matter who's a replicator who's
a human a Harrison feed did being back
on this set trigger any emotional
response or any memories of Beckman how
did your job once was good
I know what do you want I want to ask
you some questions
you